AGAINST MINNESOTA.
WEDGEWOOD GETS A BIG START
STEVE: ALL ALONE!
TYLER SE THE PAN --
YOU WIN A PUCK BATTLE AND THENEN
FIVE-ON-FIVE.
KLINGBERG ANANSSIVE.
NOW, A BREAK AND A SHOT CATCHES
THE NETTING.
KLINGBER END
FROM KILLORN TO HAGEL. HOW HE'SO
LOT OF HIS GOALS
AND IT'S COMING UP.
CIRELLI GOT THE SHOT AWAY.
AND A GOOD
HAGEL.
CIRELLI ATTACKED FROM THE SLOT.
UP HIGH.
HE BEATS
GREAT STUFF BY
THERE'S POINT IN THE MIDDLE E .
STEVE: MOMENTS THAT MATTER
BROUGHT TO YOU BY EXPEDIA.
SECOND PERIOD IS NOW UNDER
OPPORTUNITY, SHOT, LOOKED LT PLT
AND A BIG SAVE.
VA
BRAIDS POINT MAKES THE SHOT.
-- BRAYDEN POINT MAKES THE SHOT.
SUTER.
TESTING SCOTT WEDGEWOOD AND HIT.
SECOND CHANCE, AND VASILEVSKIY
HE GETS TO THE PUCK AND
VASILEVSKIY MAKES THEEVSKIY HASO
MAKE A COUPLE OF BIG SAVES
THE POINT SHOT THROUGH TRAFFIC.
AND HE GETS RAFFL ONCE.
AND HAD ONLY 29 SHOT
KUCHEROV GOT IT AWAY.
AND WED FROM POINT.
PUCK, HE'LL
GET THERE AND WEDGEWOOD THE
COMING OVER FROM TAMPA BAY HE'S
STARTING FITTING.
IT'S A SLOPPY PASS FROMHE
SERGACHEV.
HE ROBS ONDREJ PALAT,
FOLLOW, CLOSE DOWN THE BOTTOM OF
THE NET
CERNAK, GOT IT SWASHINEWOOD HASD
Y
VASILEVSKIY.
AND THEN IT HITSOT A PIECE.
WEDGEWOOD HAD TO BE REAY
LEAGUE.. A POSITION
WHERE PAVELSKI CAN FIND HIM.
STEVE: TURNOVER, HERE'S BENN,
GOT THE SHOT.
STOPPED BY VASILEVSKIYN'T BANG .
IT'S